what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg got it okay caved you
got a new beating order in the mail and
I was like okay this one is cleaner and
shinier and the D's definitely stand out
more maybe this was a blessing in
disguise but I didn't get aware for last
time so anyway John how are you I'm
great I'm just happy for you thanks John
cool how are you are you saying some
sort of new suit you have in your head
seems to be a worked out it's awfully
red food better too strange koi follow
koi genre over on Tick Tock 15 seconds
30 seconds 30 minute video sometimes ten
who knows leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also uh we always say
this full interaction watch long as we
sync up with your own copy available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
but just for you know fun we'll make it
public anyone who wants to do it can
sync up with us it's free for everyone
for the finale why not there's a link in
the pin comment and the description box
lastly with that in mind stick around
for as we say thank you to G fuel for
sponsoring this video I just down to G
fuel right now actually about you could
ask these guys I'm drinking G fuel every
single day it's been that way for months
so when we were asked to partner up with
them it was an instant yes because I
only want to be working with people
where it's like yeah I actually do use
your product or a version of your
product and G fuel is one I use every
day I often give it to koi too it helps
me do those late night lists yeah it's
gonna help me stay up editing tonight as
well so it helps me with energy focus
and right now if you use promo code
reject Nation 30 off this weekend I'm
telling you guys it's well worth it no
weird crash I'll say it sometimes unlike
you know adrenaline things it makes you
and not this yeah I can vouch
normally I'm like you don't need to
oversell it but it is true so yeah thank
you
Walters
[Laughter]
oh yes accidental dose of chemistry
oh that's gross I love this
angry or outraged a startling
metamorphosis occurs what a great
tribute
this is so good
yes the bleacher is driven by rage I
wonder if that's the onset reference and
pursued by online trolls
don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when I'm angry
glasses
oh
[Music]
what that was a hell of a trivia man
they baited you
did you and oh
oh no she's gonna go to Abominations
group therapy the hulked or the forest
inhibitor sweetheart it's all right
people go to prison every day
so supportive dad oh she's gonna really
realize how much she misses being the
She-Hulk and it's gonna bring them
together
get him down I don't care if there is a
drought I got water pressure for days
that's an Easter egg for the California
drought one of these guys is gonna slip
up and they're gonna give us enough
information so that we can track them
down and then we will find them and we
will destroy them
legally
I said Bayonne no
that opening was so cool it was a lot
over it yeah beautiful right after World
finite spooky season you might get a
kick out of this video that Jen and her
friends made
this no no no no no
She-Hulk was twerking all the way back
then this isn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
it
we're not doing a narrator we're not
there
no do it please whose voice was that I'm
not running from my problems it's a
mental health break
yep very La yep sometimes you got to go
to Ohio forgive me Jen for this turn
Nikki
oh hey there Holt King damn hell yeah
I'll be there
are you still here
I just need a place to stay for a couple
of days of course of course I'll set you
up with a guest room okay a nug
okay
deep hikers you're coming in real choppy
and ladies more it guys she just sucks
okay and I'm not just saying that
because she's a female I would have the
exact same criticism if she was a man
let's do it pug okay come on
come on Pros females am I right yeah
oh so happy that you're here
yeah me too so happy
[Music]
first he rules and he's hot
and he's hot he's hot in case you got
everything through nepotism she got
everything through nepotism exactly
you think she boned Holloway
[Music]
yes like you're mad about it yeah and it
pisses me off
I created Intelligentsia
I'm Hulk King oh
we never saw that coming what a Twist
it's okay he can improvise
oh oh no oh the guy can't Improv
it's easy just say virtue signaling and
woke culture a few times you'll get your
Social Justice Warrior
but I don't think anybody can really
understand what I'm going through right
now except a meal since he went through
literally the exact same thing is the
meal involved with intelligence he's not
there oh yeah yeah he's down the lodge
some private event down there oh no yeah
I mean it was evolved no give it up
no
oh my God
[Applause]
no I don't believe it oh I do believe it
I hear your group is over be making
amazing progress every single person
seizing their goal am I right
Robin's Hulk hey
[Applause]
Jordan Peterson Hulk Jennifer
oh
you've been forming into the Abomination
uh yeah I
had engagements that's
not me for profit
oh boy Todd created the site he's Hulk
King
uh
[Applause]
went on my blood so we could save
is he gonna become the Red Hulk or
punchline Hulk
genetics don't line up man he's turning
green
ah this can't possibly be where this
season was going
on
[Applause]
surprise losers what
come on Titania too
I'm confused about the allegiances
it's not what you think
oh rematch
what is even happening here I know I
don't know
none of these storylines make any sense
is this working for you
hey what do you think you're doing
you got me yeah
see
[Music]
no whoa this is genius of Disney Plus
genius use of Disney plus wow holy balls
this is wild
I'm so happy right now
[Music]
I can't believe this has happened we've
literally walked around here yeah this
is this is amazing
foreign
[Laughter]
what the hell you guys what kind
of bit finale is this
kind of a Twist a Twist the bad guy
steals my blood in order to give himself
superpowers where did you come up with
that original idea
why don't we just do things our own way
this is the story that Kevin wants oh my
God
are we about to talk to Kevin
no one talks to Kevin
[Music]
I would murder you to protect Kevin
I'm going to go talk to Kevin now
oh my God is this happening
Jesus
is this really what the floor looks like
this is New York let me just have you
Center non-disclosure agreement and then
have a seat
Hulk
you shouldn't read some of that Jen
ier
oh we're not gonna see Kevin we gotta
see Kevin we gotta see Kevin
that I want you posters everywhere
ow
ow
I want you to put away your cell phone I
need that poster
wow this is
wildly meta
Kevin
hello Jennifer
Kevin it stands for knowledge enhanced
visual interconnectivity
buggies are you expecting a man
oh
I will answer your questions but you
must first transform back to Jennifer
why
you are very expensive
[Laughter]
team hasn't gone to another project
oh my God the Black Panther's out I
possess the most advanced entertainment
algorithm in the world and it produces
near perfect Products near
some are better than others but I leave
that debate up to the Internet
can we agree that it is a legal comedy
if that's what you prefer to call it
then I would like to give my closing
argument the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is known for its big spectacles and high
stakes plot lines often said that Marvel
movies all in the same way wow this is a
result of following some Unwritten rule
that you have to throw a bunch of plot
and Flash and whole blood thing that
seems super suspiciously close to Super
Soldier serum
distracts from the story which is that
my life fell apart right when I was
learning to be both Jen and She-Hulk
those are my Stakes Kevin
the k-e-v-i-n is processing this new
data erasing blood clot oh and and Bruce
but Bruce is supposed to return to
explain what he was doing no we don't
need to hear anything
let's save it for the movie
confirmation from her oh would not mind
seeing Daredevil again
historically we've been live in that
department oh
we got Tony
Thor daddy issues low-key same daddy
same issue please stop oh and when are
we getting the X-Men I cannot
[Laughter]
that's it we're done that's it you
obliterated the thrilling ending Kevin
formulated Bruce smashes buildings I
smash fourth walls and Bad Endings and
sometimes when I murdered
see you on the big screen
really is this gonna tie into Captain
America oh
should I transform back or
is it what's the most budget-friendly
way to do this
mg you guys we are about to witness a a
murderer it's like Last Action here I'll
see
Court
hey Daredevil you missed it we're done
sorry everything oh man
God did they hook up with that thing yes
look at my Daredevil Beauty
that if you sign this you go back to
prison for 10 years for violating your
parole yep
this show just shot up like 50 000
points
the finale was genius summer oh my God
yes yes thank you
now match Jen tells me you have your own
practice
yeah in the house kitchen the Hell's
Kitchen doesn't sound like a very nice
area
well it's not very glamorous but it's
where I grew up and I've always wanted
to help the people in my neighborhood
who can't afford legal services so you
don't make a lot of money
I I don't do it for the money but you do
make some money right Dad it's very
expensive raising kids in La I did not
think the conversations are going that
way Matt I'm going to tell you right now
every conversation is going in that
direction so buckle up
I really am I'm just visiting why not
stay
Welcome to My Life
[Music]
no he's joining them for dinner
cousin Bruce oh my god I've been away
it's a car for a while
tell you all about it but first I have
someone here that I'd like you all to
meet
oh Betty my son oh my God so what what
they did it I called it there he is
oh my I just threw it in there can you
share any details about your lawsuit
against Todd Phelps and Intelligentsia
people like Todd Phelps oh Phelps
this whole time you attack harm or
harass innocent people I'm coming for
you do you mean in the courtroom or as a
superhero
us
now tell our viewers who are you wearing
to court today okay
Luke Jacobson difficult Diva of law
herself I would have been excited that's
the side of Betty too you know it's just
saying
that was a great episode that was wild
as mad as the comics get they did it
like say the hope for the movie we had a
little back and forth that they might
bring Scar and I was like they had a
fast and the furious man it did it yeah
they brought him in they did that was an
incredible ending I'm so much happier
with this show now if they do a season
two they gotta keep them order like that
I mean Marvel's good at learning lessons
I think and pivoting that just like
didn't even build up The Meadows
she literally went through the frame
and we got Daredevil again this did
actually move up an entire slot in my
like experience of it
took your time
you got stopped in another show didn't
you
oh really
wongers shared fridge they're kind of
all fun with everything how about Wi-Fi
I have Wi-Fi
that's a callback
huh wowza wow zowza wowzers all right we
gotta talk about that [ __ ] my God they
did a lot all right guys that was um
that was the
I don't think they could beat the does
that beat the Daredevil episode what do
you guys think I don't think it beats
the Daredevil said for me no they're
gonna be the Daredevil episode I don't
know why technically be the better
episode
even if Daredevil's in it uh no but I do
think that it is uh to me the second
best finale of any of the Marvel shows
like it was really impressive we're
gonna have Corey do a ranking for
Corey's comic corner of uh raking the
Marvel Disney Plus shows but um yeah we
gotta talk immediately about these uh
these ending moments here because it was
it was such an interesting experience
because with the Intelligentsia sequence
when we were there I was like okay this
is fine like before this episode started
and we saw the Run timer like there's no
way
short too short and I love that
everything I was bothered by this entire
season they just acknowledged yeah like
that elevated this in a whole show
because when they're at the
intelligentsy apart and then every the
whole catastrophe of things start
happening where you know Todd's
revealing himself Abominations they're
Hulk shows up
Titania shows up I was even though Jen
was acknowledging to the audience you
know like this is crazy this is messy is
this what we wanted my mind was like
just because you're acknowledging it is
does that mean it doesn't make it not
does that mean it's good now because
you're acknowledging it and then they
went the next extra step with breaking
men like that was more meta than than
Deadpool you know in in so many ways
with walking through the Disney lot
going through the menu of the Disney
plus menu it's like this is this is like
when you stand in line for an attraction
at the theme park for like one of those
Avengers rights yeah
well because they can only do this
format through this show in this way
playing it on our TVs at home like that
could only exist like this yeah just
like in the comic book when like you
turn a panel and there's a surprise like
that only works for that medium and I
loved the way they handled it with going
to the writer's room making fun of every
step of the way of how we've handled
things so far and then messing with this
on Kevin feige and then even it works in
such a meta level with turning Kevin
into an AI into an entity of like what
people like it's already sort of like
what you imagined by the brain of Kevin
feige must actually work but they were
acknowledging like everything in that
direct X-Men would ask that the X-Men
ask um what people think about the
Marvel finales like they've paid
attention so much to the comments the
lack of sex in the MCU
more Daredevil would be nice as well and
like here's how your finales of the
Disney Plus shows tend to go there's a
formula I I really respected I feel like
some people might they'll do their think
pieces and they'll do their video USA
saying how they went too far with the
metaness because but I think they I
loved it I thought they did such an
excellent job and then when they went
back into the actual show itself and
then had such a heartwarming ending with
oh man they even brought up too with
Hulk of like we didn't either
this is like teasing that we're gonna
get another Hulk movie yeah doing a
tease like that is so ingenious instead
of an Easter egg they're like yeah you
know it's coming yeah so much more fun
clever super clever and then having
Daredevil sit down with them and teasing
the possibility then having like an
actual maybe longer lasting romance than
just a little fling that's why koi
wanted a date again I did fall in love
again and Matt came back as he fell in
love with love again too yeah and plus
you demanded it and I'm not mad at that
she made it happen with Kevin feige AI
machine the Kevin Modoc parallel that
was that was so good genius oh my God I
want to see her in Deadpool work
together now uh and then yeah what's and
so now we're at the post credit scene
what sense do you make of that uh I feel
like the post-credits scene is I think
that Wong might be helping assemble the
Thunderbolts and not realize it I think
there's gonna be a certain like they're
gonna bring it back he's gonna be
Thunderbolts officially I think he's I
think he's gonna be in the Thunderbolts
nomination that's been the main Theory
but I mean it makes sense and he's been
Gathering people people like we've seen
block Gathering people for like five
movies so like is it gonna be dark
Avengers or Thunderbolts is it maybe
he's Gathering people to fight the
Thunderbolts which side is abomination
going to be on fascinating because I
think that like there's gonna be two
sets of teams I think One's Gonna end up
being a Dark Avenger or a young Avenger
and one's gonna be the one that are
called Thunderbolts but I think the
Thunderbolts is going to be a bait and
switch wherein those are all reformed
characters if you look at the assemblage
of team we got at d23 all of those
people have been in therapy and like
they're working on their stuff so what
if the Thunderbolt twist is they all
think they're actually doing good and
then they find out their villains
instead of us as the audience finding
out these villains are here the the
people we've identified as heroes or
villains what if the characters think
they're doing right and they find out
they've been doing things wrong and that
would be a switch on the concept of
thunderbolts true and that'd be a really
fun way to do it like I think I'm doing
something right I'm doing this I'm doing
this oh wait I'm working for the enemy
I'm a thunderbolt and that subverts
expectation for Comic fans and viewers
yeah look at this look at the scar in a
second but what do you think John I
think about which part about this
Thunderbolts about the post-credits
scene or this the Enemy No I mean why my
only question then is if Wong is uh you
know organizing a team or whatever where
does that leave characters like Shang
Chi and Katie and things like that who
are confirmed to be like other Avengers
um and the power Broker Than The Power
broker
everyone's wondering coming back at some
point the Fisto and the power broker top
two most request I mean yeah this seems
like a shotgun blast of setups I don't
really know what to pin as like that's
definitely coming or not I think it
would be really interesting to see a
movie that takes place in between the
events of something else we already know
like we know if there is some kind of
other Hulk movie that fills in this
blank about how he finds Scar and brings
him back you know he's obviously going
to come back with him from that you know
that we know that from you know watching
this so I feel like it would be an
interesting way to kind of see the
timeline expand because I feel like
there's a relatively linear way in which
that has gone up until now with a couple
notable exceptions whereas now I feel
like you could almost draw from anywhere
on the timeline and thus free yourself
up that much more in light of something
like this I wish that we had to that we
got to see Bruce Banner and Daredevil
interact with each other I wish we
actually got that because sometimes they
shoot these scenes in in uh in the
Marvel movies and stuff where they're
not even in the same room and they're
gonna say who they're talking to but she
says that's my cousin to uh Charlie Cox
so I'm like so he that's what I was like
oh are they actually gonna talk
yeah but how great is it like this deep
into phase four now it's just people
meeting again like we've got all new
meet cute like in Phase One like there's
all these new characters I thought
because when scars usually scar can be
like pretty uh scarves like a big is
intense yeah and I was thinking as being
like this monolith yeah exactly not like
a woman
he had such a such a childlike teenager
quality and a very silly haircut like a
teenager yes my first guess was Betty
because I thought my now I didn't I
thought they were I thought because the
show was saying we'll Reserve everything
for the whole country yeah
I was like because you're seeing
relationships and [ __ ] I just wanted
someone to crack a Corona who is playing
scar
God that's like I'm trying to pinpoint
the face because it's such a good CGI it
looks great it does I mean the CGI on
this episode definitely improved they
gave him some time I feel like it might
be a dream just young Mark Ruffalo I did
enjoy the fact they gave us that wakanda
uh sound cue and they were like the
artist went on to another project
already
yeah who is that it looks like it'd just
be Mark Ruffalo he's handsome I see I'm
sitting here going I feel like I've seen
that face that face yeah now I can't Peg
it I wonder if the credits say who
played him
I wonder if they'd even write SCAR or if
that would be like a leak
uh man yeah I mean we all thought it
would be scarf from the with them you
and I made a video about it yeah a lot
of people made videos about we can't but
we can't be the only one we are the only
people we're the only people the
concepts
no one had the idea until we came along
wait there are other comic book
commentaries I don't think so okay I
mean that's the whole point I think
we'll click here koi you're drunk I
don't want people and they also when
they went to the the metaverse that it
went uh trademark Facebook yeah then
they went into uh they went into like an
IMAX ratio for it yeah I really enjoyed
the frame expanding to be more realistic
because you know you're watching this
with frame you don't notice it and then
when it expands it feels Larger than
Life it feels like it's reaching out to
you they also use really interesting
angles so like in a comic book A lot of
times when you break the fourth wall
they've got to change the dynamic of the
frame so it looks different I really
like that they were able to do that with
extreme high and low shots so it feels
like a different Dynamic of show does it
feel though like a satisfying I guess my
question is is a series as a whole
other despite how great those last two
episodes are first two last two
exception
and five in the middle that's my that's
my thing is like this this to me
improved the five in the middle because
a lot of my issues were the writing and
the thinness and this acknowledged it
but in the same way that you acknowledge
that her just saying something doesn't
make me feel better about it I don't
know where I land on it because of that
yeah I feel like I've weirdly felt like
I want to go back and re-watch this
because as much as they made all the
jokes about it that I thought were
really clever I'm like but does the
character journey of Jen Walters truly
Click by the end John your thoughts I
would like to see this episode again and
the season as a whole again but yeah I
mean I will never forget the experience
of of beholding this for the first time
I am so happy in this moment I was
overjoyed by the choices they were
making however I'm curious on a re-watch
how this will feel as yeah a complete
story a complete package because I could
have watched this for 10 more minutes I
could have watched more of a lot of
these scenes and I mean yeah she has her
square off with Kevin and rewrites
everything and then we kind of snap to
the conclusion from there so
it's really thrilling to watch this
whole meta interlude go down but I am
also curious just to to note yeah after
a re-watch or or in a couple of days how
I'll feel kind of as a if this is a
well-rounded episode or if it's just a
very bold episode you know yeah because
it's like the last two were so solid in
the way and what they were setting out
to do that I feel like they're the
direction the writing the TLC and what
they wanted to accomplish there was so
spot on but we were still before we were
gonna go this meta we were still had a
primary story we were aiming to tell and
it's like does that this is the core of
that still truly captured because what
was the what was it again accepting
herself but was that struggle a real
struggle that we had to I mean I think
she had to accept herself as Jen and
then she had to accept herself as she
all because then she had to accept if
Jen and shield could co-exist and that
was kind of the it's kind of just like a
I wonder not really uh so it's
interesting this is the first show that
like uh most the six episode show I want
to be nine and this one I I kind of
would have been cool with it being like
a tighter six like if it was two two and
then like the five episodes in the
middle were like the dating instead of
necessarily the magic like they could
have just like you know maybe or even
like 45 minutes six episodes like
something about out the way this felt
like the the length of it with the punch
line maybe that's my issue because it
feels like a year ago the journey began
because you know how like Deadpool 2 as
an example of a movie that goes Super
meta yeah still has a full character Arc
for Wilson in that movie and how and
then like even uh if you get some
Deadpool too I don't need to recap the
whole thing it just it does go all meta
and it's like post credit scenes
especially but there is still a full
Journey that he goes on there that you
can really feel for and by the end of
this as as dazzled as I was by what they
decided to go with the last thing I was
really feeling for was oh yeah and Jen's
Journey was kind of like the last
thought of the journey that she had I
mean were you guys personally let me
clarify again I think Tatiana maslani
one of the best castings Marvel has ever
done yeah the scene especially with her
human with Kevin she's phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal but yeah do you
feel the um the emotional character art
was truly honestly I feel like the
closure was gotten before this episode
so this is
the real answer like I feel like I'm
like I know what her Arc was I felt that
closure this was like a denuma of of
spectacle yeah in a new way while
acknowledging it wasn't the Spectrum
very solid so I I think we got the
experience and then this gave us the by
the way it's a shield show yeah so it
worked it's still not like in my top
watch the episode it's when we listened
like there are reasons it doesn't quite
work as well as other things but this is
the only medium and only way they could
have done this and I respect that true
true and she does accept that she is
it's like yeah we saw we knew that we
knew the obvious gang going with the
meta and that's and the awareness that
we knew the trajectory would be like she
would accept that both Jen and She-Hulk
and then early on in this episode she's
like oh
yeah I do watch Eagle Creek that's all
we needed I'm like yeah we knew it was
going there and I really liked
intelligencia and stuff that I was like
I don't even think of those characters
like my brain never comprehended it and
I was like why would they go that way
and then this being like dismissive of
it it's exactly what the message boards
were yeah
like they did that really well and even
if it wasn't man I would still have the
same
thing this must have been a fun episode
I cannot imagine like all the throwaway
dialogue they got to just toss around in
that room that was a hilarious ass line
yeah I've definitely said that before
though about certain characters I feel
like I have to if I criticize some
characters I'm like guys Frick free come
at me I would still say this but I
didn't say that about Jane I thought she
was great it becomes a meme Trope you
know it all phrases like that start out
earnestly enough it's like in the
context of how you use that phrase which
is the beauty of even the writer's room
stuff right like they were able to bring
awareness to not just the other side of
cringe culture but the writing culture
and the the fourth wall break I thought
was just so masterfully done because it
kept finding new walls right like so
first you got her acknowledging the
Disney plus of it all then literally
kicking through things and then she
stays aware so that answers the who she
been talking to the whole thing and
that's what's gonna be interesting for
me is like where we go forward with her
like how much is she gonna be aware like
how omnipresent is Jen Walters and how
much can her awareness affect affect
whatever property like if she steps into
The Avengers movie you know I don't want
coosco to pause the movie you know what
I mean like I don't want I don't want
that actually solid pool there man yeah
emperor's new group slept on Disneyland
get some Emperor's New Groove merch I'd
buy it uh because yeah that is a really
great question and but we gotta talk
about that opening as well that opening
was genius I love how they did the tie
that's okay that also ties the ending a
70s opening and then you've got bookends
yeah I didn't even put that together
until right now yeah it's a perfect
bookend
um because yeah stepping into the mind
of Jen Walters but I remember being a
kid and not fully understanding the
build up of frustration but when when
David Banner
um starts turning into the Hulk after
unsuccessfully he's able to change his
tire yes so it always made me laugh like
so good that was the turning point for
like a cop friend like there's been a
buildup of [ __ ] happening I was like oh
that's what did it right does not like
tires really specifically
turned into a monster I'll never forget
that and they even learn some motion
in like actual physical makeup that was
so good and her just like yelling at the
car that shot was genius I wonder if
that's the onset reference because they
always credit the onset reference
actress for that yeah with some extra
yeah just some extra uh
and also and I said it earlier but I
think the balance of effectively for
scar being five hulks in this they did a
lot of really good work uh making them
look good and different yeah like that
the skin looked great this episode even
in the light oh man also that too it's
about the VFX
no
and a black panther joke like well and I
was like I wonder how the VFX artists
feel about this I could only imagine
them sitting there going huh
we are so tired oh I imagine that there
was a bit of there's gotta be a tad bit
of a catharsis within the joke there
always heard things are improving
because again when she's even when even
Kevin says like they've moved on to
other things already so could you gotta
change back to normal
you know it's kind of letting the
audience know that there's sometimes
these business decisions that are made
which I really do we're going from this
to wakanda Forever whatever that's like
probably the weirdest that might be the
weirdest tonal shift in the MCU history
yeah I guess the question is is like did
it what will the effects of this have
would it would have gone too meta well
season two is all a dream sequence yeah
confirmed I'm I'm really curious what
the internet does uh I mean obviously
The Internet's been exhausting with this
whole show but I'm really curious like
it is polarizing to do a meta
self-awareness thing to this level
but Kevin talking to everybody Kevin
loves everybody talks to everybody
that's the difference with the real life
Kevin Kevin feige you're great we
appreciate you and your omnipress people
are always talking about Kevin fighting
I'm just kind of talking with everyone
all the time yeah uh uh I loved it I I
want to re-watch this episode I I feel
like these last two episodes it's stuff
that was truly special and even though I
think the Daredevil episode is a better
narrative story that's why when you ask
me I'm like yeah like I like meta but I
also like contained story like this is
probably the most personally affecting
but I I love what they were able to do
by bringing in Daredevil so like 1000
yeah because
I think that you know like while that
Daredevil episode of course is so
special and near and dear to our hearts
yeah this is what this episode is what
made She-Hulk the show incredibly
special and and it was able to
retroactively make me appreciate a lot
of the choices I wasn't enjoying and
like down to the details of like knowing
certain Marvel references that only die
hards would get versus The Casual jokes
versus all those like little things like
and also I can't even imagine writing
this and knowing that you're reading all
this trolling leading up to like what's
to come or like you know Kevin feige
shepherding all this forward and then
knowing that there's gonna be a Kevin
that is referenced in this way and
they're writing around this and like
what was that approval of that script
like what was Kevin feige reading the
Kevin dialogue and like because he's so
invested like when I introduced you guys
too much Spider-Man like he's so fat
like what are the reactions what's the
experience how are you guys enjoying
like he cares about this so much no yeah
that was the first thing I thought of
was like what I would love to hear an
interview with him about this deep dive
because it's such a unique that's like
he's the only producer that has this
happened yeah and it also felt like
there was a sort of legitimate
um like not danger but you know like if
you're being meta from within your own
house there are surely things that you
cannot say that people should be
thinking yeah uh that's when I developed
my drinking problems but uh yeah like it
still felt
um for lack of a better word you know
like his kind of flirting with the line
and kind of dangerous in where they were
going with those meta things and so like
hats like you can always go further you
can always skewer harder but I was like
oh hats off to you know at least going
as far as you did and I would love to
know what the approval process for that
was like and I love the Matrix of it all
like I felt like the architect yeah I
almost I almost threw that out there but
I was so wrapped so phase seven will be
the after Multiverse Saga it's gonna be
the the metaverse oh 100 yeah
Kevin feige dead Hulk
um all right guys well what did you
think about this man that was wild that
was freaking wild
um I can't wait to see like I was
telling you before you showed up I was
like look man I I there are people who
apparently they've read some leaks and I
was like I haven't I haven't read them
um I would have guessed some things on
camera to make myself seem smart like is
she investigation
I wouldn't believe this league I was
like I heard their leaks are crazy so we
got to make sure I was like telling like
koi like maybe we wanted to film
something afterwards or something yeah
and I got here early and like stayed off
my phone I was like I don't want to see
anything on the journey yeah I have
friends who rather like these things are
true this is crazy and I I was like okay
so what like she like red hulks that's
what I was like he's ready is that
what's gonna happen that's where my mind
was going of like what characters could
show up that would make this a crazy
finale when you said crazy I was like
Deadpool
is the fourth wall break yeah that's
that's how you Safeguard yourself from
leaks just make yes make the reality
sound way too outlandish to be true but
then uh but man that was I I would my
mind never ventured it would go that
wild like this is beyond whatever people
delivery yeah they delivered like
describing that story is not as good as
what they showed and that's so a last
bit sorry last rant the thing the thing
I was talking okay
the thing I always talk about with these
things is the MCU is different from the
comics right I always use Civil War as
an example and like the way you keep
these things fresh is you have it evolve
from the medium for the medium so what
worked in Civil War the comic doesn't
necessarily work in Civil War the movie
what's great about The Shield episode is
this showed us why these things should
be on Disney Plus versus in the theater
I've been saying like I'd rather have
things in the movie theater I've been
saying I'd rather have these experiences
this just showed me the benefit of the
medium of watching something at home in
a way that I never would have expected
with the only character that made that
work so this is so unique to Disney plus
to me and just warmed my heart that you
could even prove me completely wrong I'm
so happy this lives here
and it's really sold that moment where
you cut back to the menu I could feel
the tension in the room when you go back
to the Disney plus menu it's like I was
like oh [ __ ] this is gonna be so hard to
re-sync before I can feel it
oh God it's gonna be so stressful so as
much as I would love to as much as this
is the episode I'm like I wish I could
see this on a big screen with some of
that scope change I'm like this is also
like really well suited to its medium
yeah I mean you wouldn't exactly because
of the scope change that's the main
reason why but
um that kick that first kick I I can't
wait to watch us go
and then see her like saying through
because that's that's something that
could only happen here and then we're
watching us watch our fourth wall break
16 walls guys what did you think about
this episode uh leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that Bell leave a
like uh let's see who the lucky patron
of the day shout out is
Fox you are the She-Hulk of this channel
you are a badass you are a virtuous
human being and if there's anybody I
would love to see break our fourth wall
and change some things around maybe for
the better I think it would be you you
got good judgment you got good taste
you're somebody who I feel like is
supportive but Stern you would take us
in the right direction it would be mad
cat but it would be beautiful my dear
and I hope you're doing well out there
stay beautiful stay sexy and we'll talk
to you soon much love I advantage of the
list you will never been shouted out
congratulations folks you just got the
finale
be happy
[Music]